أنا رينال ميدين
بدأت في البداية كممثلة ومضيفة تلفزيونية ،
بعض الأفلام التي عملت عليها
في هوليوود كانت ترسل رسائل عبر الرسائل النصية للمدينة أيضًا
وقد قمت بالعديد من الأفلام والبرامج التلفزيونية الأخرى
، ثم وجدت غرض حياتي الحقيقي الذي
أحضره للنساء  معًا في مكان آمن
للأخوة بعيدًا عن الخزي المجتمعي
والحكم
على النساء العربيات
اللواتي ولدن
بالذنب نشأن بالذنب
مشروط بالذنب والعار الذي يشبه
الأكسجين بطريقة
سمعة المرأة وعذرية المرأة
هي ختم الشرف  على الأسرة
ومن ثقيل للغاية
أن تكون مذنبًا لكونك مرتاحًا في
جسمك ، فأنت مذنب
للاستمتاع بحياتك الجنسية وشعورك بالقوة ،
أنت مذنب فقط لزعزعة الريش من
حولك كنساء ونحن ولدنا في
هذه طريقة  السيطرة على النساء
لأنك إذا
أزلت ضغوط الشرف من
أكتاف النساء ، فإن النساء أحرار
، ولهذا السبب أنشأت الحملة
أنا أسامح نفسي ، لقد
كتبت على جسدي ما أردت أن
أسامح نفسي من أجله.  لقد كان الوقت الذي
أغفر فيه لنفسي
لأنني لست زوجة وأمًا تقليدية ،
ودعوت النساء
أيضًا إلى الكتابة على أجسادهن أيضًا ما
أردن أن يسامحوهن لأنفسهن
،
وتم إنشاء حركة
وفي يوم المرأة العالمي هذا
العام ، انتشرت الحملة على نطاق واسع كان لدينا
نساء  من جميع أنحاء العالم
يكتبون على
أجسادهم على وجوههم على أيديهم
ما يريدون أن يغفروا لأنفسهم من
أجله وهذه حقًا حركة أنا فخور جدًا
بها لأن المزيد والمزيد من النساء
يبدأن في
التحرر من الذنب  والعار
[موسيقى]
العلاج الحقيقي هو رحلة جماعية
نلتئم معًا وهذا
ما يجعلها أقوى بكثير
[موسيقى
] لقد أحدثت فرقًا كبيرًا بالنسبة
لي للتعبير عن نفسي من خلال هذه
الحملة التي
نشأت في لبنان ، كان البلد
نفسه معاقًا لأن
انتهت الحرب للتو ووجدت نفسي
أكافح من أجل الاندماج
حقًا في المجتمع حيث ينظرون
إلى الأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة كأشخاص
ضعفاء ونحن مهمشون
أحب الحملة وهي إحدى الحالات الطبية
التي أتسبب في تساقط الشعر
على الرغم من أنني في المرحلة التي أعيش فيها
بسلام مع نفسي ، فقد كنت مذنبًا
لعدم استيفاء المعايير التقليدية
للجمال لأنني لولا ذلك لما كنت
أخفي  خلف باروكة شعر مستعار أو شعر مزيف ،
حطمت الرقم القياسي العالمي في
guinness لأطول جدار لساق واحدة للأشخاص
ذوي الإعاقة ،
لقد ألهمت الكثير من الأشخاص
ذوي الإعاقة لبدء تحطيم
الأرقام القياسية
[موسيقى] من
خلال الكتابة ، أنا أسامح نفسي على جسدك
هناك شعور
بأن يتم رؤيتك وسماعك وهو شفاء للغاية
لأنه في منطقتنا من العالم
لا يزال لدينا هذا الانقسام ، إما
أنك فتاة جيدة أو فتاة قذرة ،
إما أنك فتاة يريدها الرجل
فقط  استمتع مع الزوجة ، ثم
هناك مادة للزوجة ،
الفتاة الطيبة
بالنسبة لي ، أرى عدد النساء
من العديد من الخلفيات المختلفة
يجتمعن معًا
في مساحة آمنة للأخوة حيث
يشعرن أنهن يمكنهن التحدث عن أي شيء
من  الاعتداء الجنسي على الحجاب إلى
أجسادهم إلى أحلامهم إلى مشاكل
الصحة العقلية
مع الكثير من اللطف والتضامن
أنا فخور جدًا بما نبتكره
وهي البداية فقط